just 17 when he joined the army michael
chadwick was too young to be deployed to
afghanistan
he stayed at home
but dealt with the body bags that
returned
it was a very difficult period in my
life it was um you know i probably
struggled more through those six months
than when i did finally deploy
for the seven months i was out there
um
it was it was tough it was
you know i wanted to be there more than
anything to to help them a decade into
the conflict michael would have his own
experience of war
and as british military presence in
afghanistan comes to an end
he wants the world to remember the
army's bravery and compassion
i think they can hold their heads up be
extremely proud of what they've done
especially in the spotlight in extremely
difficult conditions over the past
couple of weeks in front of the eyes of
the whole world
to do what they've done
is unbelievable
wendy rayner's husband peter was among
the
457 armed forces personnel who never
returned
i was making a sandwich for my son for
his lunch because he finished kill at
quarter past one
and um
and then i saw two men come down the
path
um
it was um
to tell me that peter had been blown up
peter's death wasn't in vain she says
but britain's strategy was
this has got to be a lesson to our
government that this never happens again
they did iraq
then they did afghanistan both
things that they did on
both of those
didn't have much of an outcome
everything reverted back to how it was
before they went in
britain's deployment is officially over
but wendy and michael and thousands of
others will have a lasting connection to
a country we spent years to protect
and just days to exit
sadia chowdhury sky news